th
どうもねだです
突然ですが自分語りをさせてください僕は
カナダに留学をしていた経験があります
第留学していたかというと
すごい
他の分館違う文化に興味があったからです
例えば違う食事だったり違う言語だったり
違う人々その全てに興味がありました
で最初の方は地域的な毎日を送れていまし
た
日本と違って体は結構学校の規制とかが
厳しくなかったり
いる方にしていたので
まあやっちゃいけないんですよ神とか曽根
したり
ルールに縛られないような生活をしてい
ました
またホームステイ先
フィリピン人の方だったんですけどその
フィリピンの文化に触れたりフィリピンの
食事に触れることができました
なんですけど途中から園生活に慣れて
しまいました
られっていうのは恐ろしいもので
そのすべて性格が新鮮じゃなくなります
そしてつまらなくなります
軟毛目的を持たないまま漠然と時間だけが
過ぎていったんですけどそんな中で唯一僕
の生活を豊かにするものが登場します
それがこれです
助け一方どっです
スキットボードを始めてもういろんな人と
スケーターとか現状をつけたとかと交流を
持てることができたり
あとは友達とパークという岩井で
スケートボードも練習場に行って事実を
高めあったり
どこより体のスケートボード生活に疲れ
ました
そのタイミングで帰国が決まったんです
けど
そしたらまあ日本でも当然スケボーを
始めるわけですよ
でもなんと日本でスケボーを始めてみたら
いろんな人から後ろ指を指されたり
いっ
白い目で見られたり
で警察にはなんと事情聴取とか植樹会して
も受けたこともあります警察に至っては別
に行動で走ってるわけでもないんですけど
普通にパークに向かう途中で変に意識を
持っていただけで足止めを食らったことも
ありました
これって何で彫って考えたわけなんですね
やっぱりそこの文化と流行ファッションが
いちばんの違いだと僕は思いました
例えばカナダだったら月後は文化として
捉えられていますそれはカナダの人々だっ
て
文化に対しては寛容になりますよね
では日本はどうでしょう日本は
ファッションとしてしまうスケボーが
広まっていません
欧米が期限のものが日本で
伝来していた
恋愛してきただけなので
日本に文化がないんですね
だから理解し難いのも事実なんですけど
本当にそれっていいんでしょうか
よくないですよね
もう皆さん考えてください者も2022年
です
皆さんが閉経使ってる iphone だっ
て
期限はアメリカですよん
利便性云々はともかく
時代は着実にグローバル会と向かってます
なのに欧米の文化ん
スケートボードとかだったりヒップホップ
のカルチャーとかだったりを卑下して差別
して見下すような感じの考えだったり
受け入れるそぶりを見せない
それはいかがなものかと
私はここで掲示したいと思います
スケボーが危険なのは重々承知ですが
スケーターが
町だけ行動でスケボーする理由は日本に
ほぼと言っていいほどパークがないからで
はないでしょうか
アメリカを例に考えてみますとアメリカ役
人口が3点2億人に対してパークの施設が
3500カ所あります
一方日本はどうでしょう
日本は
人口が約1点によく人に対してパークの数
は243カ所しかありません
単純な人口比で見たら日本に落書き
1347箇所あればいいわけです
ではなぜ日本にパークがそんなに少ないの
でしょうか
それは皆さんが文化的理解をまだスケボー
に対して示せていないからだと私は考え
ました
出る杭は打たれてしまう国民性大勢の中で
マイノリティーが否定されてしまうのは
本当に良いことなのでしょうか
つ希望をただの悪の文化カウンター
カルチャーもただの悪の文化と決めつける
良いのでしょうか
そして皆さん思い出してください
去年あったと素晴らしい快挙
日本人はスケボーのオリンピックで男女
ともに優勝を果たしております
だしちゃったら堀米選手女子だったらよそ
済みさくら選手など
パークストリートをどっちもの分野で金
メダルを取っています
そして皆さんご存知ではないでしょうか
日本人は実はオリンピック以外の世界大会
でも
すごい快挙優勝を成し遂げておりますそれ
は何でかというと好き方には進退的
アドマンページがないからだと私は
考えました
で進退的アドバンテージというのはその
身体の大きさだったり
その筋肉の量では左右されずにつけ棒って
努力の数だけ結果が覆せる競技だと私は
思っております
また日本人の職人技術な性格とスケボーは
とても相性が良いと私は考えております
打ち込み追い込みをかけレスト育成
それが好き方で結果を残すているゆえんだ
と私は考えました
海外で活躍日本人を今で披露しないと
もったいないと私は思います
なので今こそ受け入れるチャンスだと私は
思ってます
では結論スケボーは本当に悪いのでしょう
か
そうではありません
それは偏見に時間過ぎません
大衆によって悪い風に仕立て上げられてい
ます
やり玉に挙げるだけでは他の分野でも
グローバル化は不可能です
世界で奇妙な面とから乗り遅れていること
に目を背けないでまずは一度してみ
ましょう
スケボーとは何か
カウンターカルチャーとは何か
した上で
判断してみてください
知らずして批判するほど愚かなことはない
のですから
そして最後に私の目標について述べ
ましょう
私が見たい実現したいのは
日本でスケボーが文化として受けられる
そんな未来ですご清聴ありがとうござい
ました